watch
[Music]
the salt and jaramillo mine with its
informative brief on Monday, January 4
starting next Monday there will be changes to the
coronavirus testing sites at
the hotel and casino test site taxi
station will be open three days a
week  so far
the southern nevada health district has not specified which
days they will be open while at
the testing sites of a uvi and
carmen steiner announced that they will
begin requesting health insurance information
to bill health insurance
to cover the costs of  the tests
the tests will continue to be free for
Nevadans who do not have health
insurance
and although it may not seem like the season to go to
the pools, it is just around the
corner and some hotels have already begun to
prepare, among them the hotel in
remember shorts who announced  that seeks to
hire at least 400 employees for
the pools of all its properties
seeks to hire assistant lifeguards
of the cabins r  exceptionists among
other positions workers start
their work in february and work until
november for more information on
how to apply for these jobs you can
visit sao dotcom
students from clark county returned
to classes and also starting their new
positions are three new members of
the board of directors of the  school district
among them is the link garcíamorales
lisa guzmán and kelli williams who
will be sworn in today in
a special meeting next week the
board of directors meets to discuss
the learning plan and the reopening
of schools for this school year
and the libraries  county
reopen today all 25
libraries temporarily closed
last month due to rising
coronavirus cases all 25 sites
will apply safety measures
including limiting capacity to 25
% list of hours and locations are
available on our page  from
internet news now dotco  m
now we move on with your
weather forecast, a week is expected with sun and
clouds the temperatures will be
above normal today's maximum in the 60
degrees have a good day I am from
Jaramillo and this was the Spanish edition
[Music]